Hey Thoughty2 here.
Every year 10 million Americans and 275,000
Britons mysteriously go missing.
But can someone literally vanish into thin
air?
Science tells us no, but there have been many
stories that say otherwise.
One of the most bizarre of these is The Legend
of David Lang.
David Lang and his family lived on a farm
near Gallatin, Tennessee in the United States.
In September, 1880 David Lang's two children,
Sarah and George were playing in the front
yard of their family home.
Their parents, David and Emma came out of
the house into the garden.
David headed off into the field towards his
horses.
At the same time, a buggy carrying Judge August
Peck was approaching, a friend of the family.
David turned to walk back to the house and
waved to the judge.
A few seconds later, in clear view of his
entire family and the judge, David Lang disappeared
in mid-step.
Emma screamed and everyone rushed towards
the spot, thinking he had fallen into a hole,
but there was no hole.
They searched everywhere but David wasn't
to be found.
A few months later the children noticed the
spot where their father had vanished turned
yellow and wilted in a circle 4.6 m (15 ft)
in diameter.
Several months later Lang's children heard
their father's voice calling out for help
as they played near the spot, but eventually
his voice faded away and they never heard
it again.
From humble farmers to Lords.
Richard John Bingham, the 7th Earl of Lucan,
popularly known as Lord Lucan.
Disappeared without trace on the 8th November
1974, after he murdered his children's nanny
in the basement of the Lucan's family home
in London, by bludgeoning her to death.
He fled and was never seen again.
The authorities believe he drowned himself
in the English Channel.
However there have been numerous sighting
of him around the world, mainly in Africa.
An ex-detective, Duncan MacLaughlin, says
he's collected sufficient evidence to prove
that Lorn Lucan infact fled to Goa in Western
India.
A former drug dealer named Mark Winch handed
photographs to the ex-detective of an elderly
man, taken in 1991, that showed an unmistakable
likeness to Lord Lucan.
Mark Winch also explained to the detective
how he had become friendly with the man in
the photographs whilst in Goa.
He said how the man was a well-spoken gambler
who loved to play backgammon, a game which
Lord Lucan was famous for.
A single disappearance not enough for you?
How about the disappearance of an entire army
battalion?
In 1915, during World War I. Three members
of a New Zealand field company said they watched
from a clear vantage point as a large battalion
of the Norfolk Regiment marched up a hillside
in Suvla Bay, Turkey.
The hill was shrouded by a low-lying cloud;
the soldiers marched into the cloud without
hesitation.
They never came out.
When the war ended, presuming the battalion
had been captured and held prisoner, the British
government demanded that Turkey return them.
However the Turks insisted the soldiers hadn't
been captured and they had never so much as
made contact with the battalion.
If a whole battalion isn't enough for you,
how about an entire village of 2,000 people
disappearing into thin air?
In Novemeber, 1930, a fur trapper named Joe
Labelle travelled to an Eskimo village on
the shores of Lake Anjikuni in northern Canada.
Joe was very familiar with the village, he
knew it had a thriving fishing community of
about 2,000 residents.
However, this time, when he arrived the village
was completely deserted.
He found one fire still ablaze on which there
was a pot of blackened stew.
When the authorities investigated their findings
were rather disturbing.
No footprints of any of the residents were
found, how did the vacate the village without
leaving footprints?
All of the Eskimos' sled dogs where found
buried under a 12 foot snow drift, they had
all starved to death.
All of the residents' food and provisions
were found undisturbed in their huts, as if
nothing had happened.
But there was one last terrifically unnerving
discovery: all the Eskimo's ancestral graves
had been emptied.
Creepy stuff, but just as spine-tingling is
the mysterious Stonehenge disappearance in
August, 1971.
One night a group of hippies decided to pitch
tents in the centre of the stone circle and
spend the night.
They built a campfire and smoked a few joints
of weed.
At 2am a powerful thunder storm quickly encroached
upon the Salisbury Plain, home to Stonehenge.
Lightening ravaged the area.
Two witnesses, a policeman and a farmer, reported
that the stones of the ancient monument lit
up with an eerie blue light that was so intense
they had to avert their eyes.
They heard screams from the campers and the
two onlookers rushed to the scene expecting
to find injured bodies.
But they found no one, the hippies had vanished.
All that remained were several smouldering
tent pegs and a drowned out campfire.